you are obviously keen to be seen as the
tax reducing chancellor but do you
accept that the tax burden is now up
yes well good morning i think first of
all to put it in context you have to
remember i was also the chancellor who
had to
oversee what happened during the
pandemic that's the first time that's
happened in through 100 years we had the
biggest economic shock in 300 years and
borrowings spiraled up to levels we
haven't seen since world war ii i had to
introduce things like furlough so that's
the context for all the actions that
i've had to take but i know families are
struggling right now with the cost of
living which is why yesterday i
announced a tax plan which delivers the
biggest net cut and personal taxes in
over a quarter of a century cutting fuel
duty five pence a liter raising national
insurance thresholds giving 30 million
workers a tax saving with typical
workers saving 330 pounds and cutting
income tax for the first time in 16
years putting more money in people's
pockets so whilst i can't solve every
problem and i've always been honest with
people about that well i can make a
difference of course that's what i want
to do and i think the plan that we
announced yesterday will do exactly that
and support hard-working british
families but but are you being honest
you know when you're talking about tax
cuts but the fact is that the overall
burden of taxes is going to reach the
highest level since the late 1940s in
the next couple of years taxes are going
to be higher than they have ever been
and that and that is a reflection
of two things first and foremost the
fact that we've experienced as i said uh
a pandemic that was a pretty exceptional
episode in our country's history
borrowing spiraled up to levels we
haven't seen the since the second world
war biggest economic shock in three over
300 years
and had to introduce interventions like
furlough i think most people will
understand that an exceptional
experience like that probably does lead
to an exceptional response and that's
what we're now grappling with the
aftermath of kovid but also we are
continuing to invest in public services
and i think you know that's what your
viewers and people want us to to be able
to do as well particularly and most
importantly the nhs and social care
getting on with tackling the backlog
there pulling more police officers on
the street putting more money into our
classrooms those are all the things the
government is doing we're seeing very
strong investment in public services
over this parliament
and that of course needs to be paid for
but but there are those who will say
that what you did yesterday
didn't go far enough and didn't actually
help the very poorest in society there's
no increase in universal credit there's
no increase in pensions no increase in
disability benefit
the very poorest in society do not earn
enough to benefit from the announcements
that you made yesterday do they they are
not going to benefit from an increased
national insurance
threshold or a one percent tax cut
because they just simply don't earn
enough and for those people there was
nothing yesterday
well they actually are my priority which
is why we started our action to help
them in the autumn in my autumn budget
we made the operation of universal
credit more generous so that people can
keep more of what they are and
especially those people that you're
talking about on low incomes they will
also benefit and that what we did then
was a two billion pound tax cut for
about two million low earners they will
also disproportionately benefit from the
significant increase in the national
living wage that's just about to come in
it's going to go up 6.6
now the combination of all these things
means that for example let's take a
single mother with two children renting
working full time on the national living
wage so a low earner as you described
that that mother is going to be
1600 pounds a year better off as a
result of all these decisions and it's
right that we are focusing attention on
them but i do believe the policies that
we're putting in place will help those
people on low incomes disproportionately
in fact that's what you believe but but
it's not what other people who've
examined what you've you've set out
yesterday believe you know the
resolution foundation says that
two-thirds of the benefits you announced
yesterday will will help only the top 50
tax cuts for middle and top earners only
one in three of the pounds that is going
to be saved goes to the least well-off
and you look at what you've
you've really flagged up to us
today about fuel duty going down five
pence a liter that only helps if you've
got a car a third of the population
don't have access to a car um
it it just seems to add to the to the
feeling that maybe you're not really in
touch with the hard reality of lots of
people's lives
actually when i go out about talking to
people fuel duty is one of the things
that is raised most often with me
because the vast majority of people in
this country do use their cars to get
around particularly those in rural areas
particularly those on lower incomes for
whom petrol bills are are a much larger
part of their income so this is
something actually that's reviewed we've
got a lovely picture of what happened
if i could just finish if i could just
finish answer the finish answering the
question and and actually talking to the
person who was doing that with it you
know they use their car every day to get
to work they notice obviously petrol
prices going up you know they were
appreciative of the fact that we're
cutting fuel duty it does demonstrate
we're on the side of people accepting
that we can't solve every problem or
fully fully make up for some of the
increase in petrol prices but with
regard to low earners and you mentioned
one thing tank you know that
also other think tanks including the one
that you mentioned but the independent
institute of fiscal studies for example
has specifically described what we did
on national insurance thresholds as is
the best way through the tax system to
help those on low incomes and middle
incomes because i think the increase in
national insurance thresholds yet that
we put in place yesterday which will
come into effect in july is particularly
well targeted to help those on lower
middle incomes it will provide a tax cut
for 30 million workers and it's worth
for a typical employee about 330 pounds
a year so it does demonstrate we're on
the side of hard-working british people
that's what this government is about and
that's what i'm delivering the ifs
may suggest that you may be slightly
representing them i have a quote from
their director paul johnson yesterday
says what really stands out today is
what's missing he has done nothing more
for those dependent on benefits the very
poorest beside a small amount of extra
cash for local authorities their
benefits will rise by just 3.1 percent
for the coming financial year the cost
of living could well well rise by 10 so
the ifs are not
wholeheartedly welcoming what what you
announced yesterday has to be said let's
look at that picture of you filling up
your car um you're looking very jolly
it's a gorgeous sunny day yesterday
wasn't it um
most people when they fill up their car
these days
watch the pounds going up going up going
up it struck me that you weren't even
looking at how much it costs to fill up
your car do you fill it up very often
well actually i was having a
conversation with a person uh that i was
talking to at the same time that's
filling it up and we and we were filling
it up and i was keeping an eye on the
pounds and actually it was about 30
pounds and one pence i didn't quite get
to finish it in the right place so yes i
was keeping an eye on it but i think you
you were just having a conversation
about filling up you were just you were
just like about a quarter of a tank
well that's what was required but you i
mean one second ago you were saying that
all fuel doing something on fuel duty
isn't particularly valuable and and now
we're having conversation saying that it
is i think actually it is it's the
biggest ever i'm not saying that pure
duty isn't valuable
and i think and i think it will it will
make a difference to people i mean i
might you know my wife and i have
volkswagen golf and actually she's
filled it up as they're saying the other
week and and it is it is going up of
course we know it's going up and that's
why we took action uh yesterday to try
and make a difference there with the
biggest ever cut in fuel duty that we've
seen at five pennsylvania
and i'm really glad actually to see
retailers passing that on very quickly
and you know i hope that that happens
across the industry something i called
for yesterday and i'd see i think asda
and sainsbury's in particular were quick
out of the block saying that they were
doing that and i'm i'm grateful to them
for doing that so that your viewers we
can all benefit from that fuel duty cut
as quickly as possible
but there are those who who will will
will look at you and say that that you
aren't really in touch with real
people's lives i mean you've had a very
lucky and privileged life and i know
you've talked about the sacrifices your
parents made to send you to an excellent
school um but
i would suggest that you've never had to
worry about making a fiver last till the
end of the week
and there are a lot of people who who
are looking at what was announced
yesterday and we're talking to one of
them just after eight clark about a man
called barry who's a carer for for two
children who have got health issues his
wife's a care worker
and there was nothing there yesterday
they say for them that will make their
lives any easier and they're looking at
the with horror at the idea that
inflation could go up to as much as 10
percent
well you know this has been put to me
many times and what i say is judge me by
my actions i think people can see how
i've acted over the last couple of years
as our country went through a very
difficult period and i think i
demonstrated that i am standing by
british people when we go through
difficult things i introduce things like
furlough i help this country get through
a pandemic and partly because of the
actions that i took the economy is in a
much stronger place than anyone expected
now with more people on payroll than we
have before the pandemic unemployment
back down to the record low levels we
saw before the crisis that doesn't
happen by accident that happens because
of the policies that we put in place and
it's because of that that we can now
help people to whether some of the
challenges ahead accepting of course as
i've said we can't solve every problem i
wish i could and that's the toughest
part of this job not being able to do
everything that people want you to do
but where i can make a difference of
course that's what i'm doing and again
you know you talk about barry and his
family obviously you can't get into
everyone's individual circumstances but
i i do think families will benefit from
the fuel duty cut we announced yesterday
because many people are reliant on their
cars that will help
millions of people tens of millions of
people will benefit from the increase in
national insurance thresholds that's
going to save people 330 pounds a year
they'll benefit from the increase in the
national living wage they'll benefit
from the increased generosity of the
universal credit taper they'll benefit
from the extra money that we're giving
councils to help those most in need and
they will benefit from the income tax
cut that's coming down the line so look
there's a range of things we're doing
all of which demonstrate we are on the
side of hard-working british families
and that's what we will continue to do
how'd you say well the prime minister
has just uh made a statement apparently
he said we can do more to stop putin
from using his gold reserves what should
we be doing
i'd say no i i'm not sure the context of
exactly what the prime minister has said
that i'm talking to you but what i would
say is you know he's taken a lead and
deserves enormous credit for galvanizing
international opinion to deliver a
strong message he must have asked your
opinion as a chancellor
about the gold reserves well
yeah well there's lots of things we're
doing about the central bank and i've
seen that's what he's what he's talking
about and we've taken a leading role in
sanctioning russia particularly economic
and financial sanctions i outlined those
yesterday in parliament they are having
an impact and people should feel uh
reassured that what we are doing is
having an impact the russian ruble has
plummeted to record lows the moscow
stock exchange has been essentially
closed for a month and the russian
central bank has had to double interest
rates to 20 in russia so all the various
things we're doing
are having an impact and as the prime
minister said we will continue to
maintain pressure on russia
you you mentioned that you mentioned the
pressure on russia um
it's been reported uh that you've got
family links to russia that your wife
apparently has a stake in the indian i.t
consultancy firm infosys
they operate in moscow they have an
office there they have a delivery office
there they've got a connection to the
alpha bank in moscow
are you giving advice to others that
you're you're not following in your own
home
that's not as i i'm an elected
politician and i'm here to talk to you
about what i'm responsible for my wife
is not
she is not but but equally if you you
know as a country we are asking
taxpayers to fund the uk's support for
ukraine we're asking people in the uk to
give their homes up to ukrainian
refugees
whereas it appears your family
potentially could be benefiting from
putin's regime
no i i really i don't think that's the
case and as i said the the operations of
all companies are up to them uh we've
we've put in place significant sanctions
and all the companies that we're
responsible for are following those as
they rightly should sending a very
strong message uh to putin's aggression
do you know if infosys is
i i have i have absolutely no idea
because i have nothing to do with that
company
okay
um
in terms of of what the prime minister
is saying he is saying that we could be
doing more to stop putin what would you
like to see the british government doing
more
to stop putin and and where will that
money come from we've talked about a new
support package for ukrainian forces 6
000 more anti-tank missiles is this
going to come from our existing defense
budget
also we we knew that russia was a
particular threat to our security uh
because in the something called the
integrated review which was done a
little while ago it was named very
specifically is a big threat and that's
why we increased our defense budget by
record amounts 24 billion pounds over
the four year period that's the biggest
increase in defense spending since the
end of the cold war in reflection of the
new threats that we face and it's
because of that extra investment in
defense that we're able to provide
support to our allies like ukraine at
this difficult time and we know that
that is making a difference to their
ability to withstand russian aggression
and i hope people are proud of the
contribution that the british state and
armed forces are playing
chancellor rishi sunak thank you very
much for joining us so we appreciate
your time
thank you